-And you know what?
Those jokes were
mostly pretty good.
But to get those 10 or 11 jokes,
our monologue writers
have to write
hundreds of jokes every day.
And I'll be honest with you,
they're not all good.
And, honestly, sometimes,
I think they throw in
some real stinkers
just to fill up a page
and meet the assignment,
which is understandable.
Joke writing is a grind,
and they work really hard.
But now that we
have audiences again,
that kind of laziness --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, give yourselves
a round of applause.
That kind of laziness
has got to stop,
which means it's time for a
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Fanfare ]
Way too long.
[ Laughter ]
So, here's how this works.
These jokes -- These are real
jokes submitted by my writers
that are unusable for the show.
Some are dumb,
some are patently offensive,
and some are just baffling.
Most importantly, the writers
don't know we're doing this,
and because a lot of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know
that we're doing this.
So, let's get to it.
A Eurasian eagle owl named
Gladys recently escaped from
a zoo in Minnesota after
she flew into a tree
during a training session
and did not return.
Her friends were no help.
When asked if
they had seen Gladys,
all they said was, "Who?"
[ Laughter ]
Don't.
[ Laughter continues ]
Brian wrote that joke.
There's a picture of Brian.
Brian is a dad,
so it's okay for him to tell
a stupid [bleep] dad joke.
It's legal.
Michigan State University
recently asked faculty and staff
to volunteer to work in the
dining halls without extra pay
amid an ongoing labor shortage.
Luckily, the Jell-O has tenure.
I fully don't get it.
Makes no sense to me.
Baze, does it make sense to you?
-No.
-Okay, good.
It was just like,
"Jell-O's funny."
Matt Goldich wrote that.
Let's see Matt. There he is.
Matt made of Jell-O.
Amid global supply-chain delays,
toy makers, reportedly,
are planning to release more
small, squishy toys
this holiday season.
"You mean rabbits?",
asked Lennie?
So, that joke requires
a very specific knowledge of
the book or film
"Of Mice and Men,"
where Lennie does not know
his strength.
He kills rabbits.
Squishes them so hard
that he kills them.
'Cause some people don't know
their own strength,
so then they harm people.
Other people don't know
their own weakness
and they wear tank tops to work,
like Scollins...
who wrote that joke.
According a new survey,
half of Americans said
if they could time-travel,
they would prefer
to move forward in time.
"Thank you," said baby Hitler.
And, again, you might not
think that joke is funny,
but here is
something that's very funny.
Someone allowed their child to
be used for stock photos.
"What's the worst they can do?"
According to new reports,
some areas of the country
are experiencing
a pumpkin shortage,
but in other news,
there has been a surplus of
jack-o'-lanterns.
Oof.
I almost feel bad showing you --
Like, you literally --
Not one of you went for a joke
by the nicest person
on our staff.
That's Karen.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Too late.
According to new reports,
some areas of the country
are experiencing
a pumpkin shortage,
which will cause prices
to increase.
It's a phenomenon known to
economists as "pumpkinflation."
Ian.
According to new reports,
a drought in California
has caused a pumpkin shortage.
This is one of the nice things
about working at this show,
is, you know, 'cause they all
hear about pumpkin shortages,
and then they just grind out
unusable joke
after unusable joke.
Let's see -- I'm gonna just say
in advance, it's Ally's joke.
We're 0 for 2 on
pumpkin shortage.
Karen ate it hard.
Ian ate it hard.
It's up to Ally to save us
on the pumpkin shortage.
Let's see if she can do it.
According to reports,
a drought in California
has caused a pumpkin shortage.
All we can do now is pray to
gourd for some rain.
[ Light applause, laughter ]
I think we can say -- I think
the best we could say is
Ally is the king
of [bleep] mountain.
The indie band Bon Iver
announced yesterday they'll
launch a U.S.-and-European tour
next year.
But if you want to see them
live, you must have taken
at least your first dose of
Bon Ivermectin.
Let's take a look at
who has tenure.
[ Laughter ]
A turtle recently hatched
in Massachusetts
with two heads and six legs,
which,
by Massachusetts standards,
still makes her a 9.
[ Light applause ]
Yeah, you can clap.
You can clap.
Mike Scollins wrote that joke,
and he's from Massachusetts
and he tries to get me
in trouble.
According to a new survey,
19% of Americans
say that they feel older
than their actual age.
"Yeah, that's not going to
help your case,"
said R. Kelly's lawyer.
Same dude.
There he is.
Oh, no. No, no, no.
One of them writes for us.
I can never remember.
This segment is over now
and I'm going to say it's over,
and then we're gonna
have to watch
that awful
graphics package again.
So I just apologize.
Just brace yourselves.
Just zone out for the next --
What?
I think -- What is it?
95 seconds?
This has been
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Fanfare ]
Did the title card play?